men have been arrested in connection
with a new year's eve crime spree metro
has arrested 20-year-old jasoni carter
and 20-year-old jordan ruby as suspects
in deadly shootings at fashion show mall
and palace station officers also say an
employee was shot at at sahara hotel and
casino but wasn't hurt detectives say
the suspects were trying to commit
robberies with each of with when each of
these shootings happen rather a man we
spoke with shares what he saw at fashion
show
he was yelling they tried to rob us and
we wouldn't give him anything and he's
calling 9-1-1 so there was another
witness there that was uh saying it was
a black gentleman with a dreadlocks that
got into a car and took off
detectives are still reviewing these
suspects connections to other events
they are both being charged with open
murder but police say more charges are
anticipated
meanwhile a suspect is still on the
loose tonight after a separate shooting
at meadows mall responding officers say
they found two victims one with a
gunshot wound near the round one both
were taken to the hospital and are
expected to be ok
investigators believe the victim got
into a fight with the suspect and shots
were fired